problema número 70 si x 5 es mayor que 2
y x menos tres es menor que 7 en cual
rango de valores deberá estar x
bueno aquí lo que nos dicen es que x + 5
es mayor que 2 y x menos tres es menor
que 7
y aquí vamos a restar 2 en ambos lados
de la desigualdad por lo que nos hace
cambiar el sentido de la desigualdad y
nos va a quedar que x es mayor que menos
y de aquí abajo vamos a sumar 3 en ambos
lados como estoy sumando algo positivo
el signo de desigualdad se queda igual
entonces va a quedar x menor que 7 + 3
10 y en nuestro rango queda menos 3
menor que x x menor que 10
que esta es nuestra opción
muy bien siguiente problema que de hecho
ya lo podemos ver aquí pero voy a
ponerlo para que podamos tener espacio
para escribir números 71 una clase de
gimnasia puede dividirse en ocho equipos
con el mismo número de integrantes cada
uno o en dos equipos con el mismo número
de integrantes o de estudiantes cuál es
el menor número de estudiantes en la
clase básicamente lo que nos dicen es
que el número de estudiantes en el grupo
es divisible tanto entre 8 como entre 12
y lo que nos preguntan es cuál es ese
menor número divisible entre 8 y 12 o el
mínimo común divisor ok entonces tenemos
que 8 grupos con el mismo número de
estudiantes igual 8 grupos iguales o 12
que también son iguales en el número de
integrantes
veamos los múltiplos de 88 es divisible
entre 12 8 por 2 16 tampoco es divisible
entre 12 8 por 3 24 24 si es divisible
entre 12 por lo que tenemos 24
estudiantes que es mi opción b
siguiente problema número 72 al menos
dos tercios de los cuarenta miembros de
un comité deberán votar a favor de una
resolución para que sea aprobada cuál es
el mayor número de miembros que pueden
votar en contra de una resolución y ésta
pueda ser aprobada lo que nos preguntan
es el mínimo número de miembros
necesarios para que se apruebe la
resolución y ese número restarlo a 40
cuánto es dos tercios de 40
esto es igual a 80 tercios dividimos 80
entre 33 por 268 menos 62 bajamos el
cero
6 x 3 18 18 menos 20 nos queda 2
tendremos que poner un punto decimal
aquí baja un 0 y de nuevos 6 por 3 18
estamos cada dos y así seguiría el 6 de
manera infinita
pues no podemos tener 26.6 personas una
fracción de personas no puede votar así
que vamos a tener esto que aproximarlo a
27 personas entonces necesitamos al
menos 27 personas que voten a favor 27
al menos
y voten
a favor
cuando necesitamos que voten en contra
pues será 40 menos 27
igual a 13 entonces lo que nos preguntan
es que son 13 el número máximo de
personas que puede votar en contra y aún
así se ha aprobado la resolución y esta
es nuestra
opción
el siguiente problema número 73 en casa
de la familia pérez hay una cantidad
mensual asignada a elementos del hogar a
alimentos y cosas varias estas tienen
una proporción de 5 a 2 a 1
respectivamente si la cantidad total
asignada a estas tres categorías es de
1.800 dólares cuál es la cantidad
asignada a alimentos entonces tenemos la
categoría de el hogar cosas para el
hogar la categoría de alimentos y la
categoría de cosas varias y la
proporción es de 5 a 2
a uno
el presupuesto o la cantidad total es de
podemos verlo de esta manera alimentos
base del doble que cosas varias
alimentos
es dos veces lo asignado a varios y
gastos del hogar es cinco veces lo
asignado a varios
las cosas del hogar son cinco veces lo
podemos decir que lo asignado al hogar
más lo asignado a alimentos más lo
asignado a varios es igual a 1800
vamos a sustituir estos elementos aquí
en esta ecuación
nos va a quedar cinco cosas de varios
más
por varios más varios
igual a esta extraña iguala 1805
27 ve más 198 b8b igual a 1800
por lo que ve es igual a 1800
/ 8 esto lo puedo simplificar dividiendo
entre 2 me quedarían 900 entre 4
esto también lo puedo dividir entre 2 me
quedan 450 entre 2
y 450 entre 2 es igual a 225 esto es lo
asignado a varios b es igual a 225
lo que nos preguntan es lo asignado a
alimentos y de aquí sabemos que los
alimentos es el doble de lo asignado a
varios alimentos es igual a 2 por 225 y
esto es igual a 450 la cantidad asignada
a alimentos es 450 dólares que es
nuestra opción de
el siguiente problema
número 74 hay cuatro mujeres más que
hombres en un comité si hay diez
miembros en el comité cuántas mujeres
hay lo que nos dicen es que de mujeres
hay igual la cantidad al número de
hombres más cuatro
las mujeres más los hombres dan un total
de 10 miembros lo que voy a hacer aquí
es despejar de aquí el número de hombres
pueden estar 4 en ambos lados me queda
que hombres es igual a mujeres menos 4 y
esto lo sustituyó acá me queda que
mujeres más
xerez 4 10
aquí es 2 m y x sumó 4 en ambos lados
para que quitarlo de este lado 10 + 4 es
igual a 14 m es igual a 14 entre 2 igual
a 77 mujeres en el comité por lo tanto
habrá 3 sombras para que sean 10
y esta es mi opción de
veamos el último problema de ese vídeo
al menos número 75 juanita compró un
certificado por un año de 10.000 dólares
que tiene una tasa de interés del 8 por
ciento anual con un puesto semi
anualmente cuál fue el interés total
pagado por el certificado al llegar a la
madurez
entonces nos dicen que es certificado es
por un año un año costó 10.000
y es una tasa de interés del 8 por
ciento compuesto cuando decimos
compuestos semi anualmente significa que
ustedes reciben la mitad de los
intereses cada medio año aunque yo no sé
si en este tipo de exámenes sea una
condición que ustedes deban conocer esto
que probablemente sólo aprenderán en una
escuela de negocios pero bueno después
de seis meses aquí se la compra pasaron
seis meses cuando hice la compra o
cuando juanita hizo la cuenta aquí se
pagaron 10 mil pasan 6 meses
y aquí se van a abonar intereses el
anual es de 8% aquí es la mitad del año
por lo tanto será la mitad de estos
intereses el 4% aquí se van a agregar el
4% de la cantidad que teníamos aquí en
de los 10 mil cuánto es el 4% de 10.000
10.000 por 0.04
igual a 234 y como tenemos dos lugares
después del punto decimal vamos a
recorrer aquí 12 lugares tenemos 400
esos intereses se agregan a la inversión
inicial por lo que aquí a los 6 meses
voy a tener 10 mil 400 pero no me los
van a dar van a seguir invertidos
entonces de aquí van a pasar otros 6
meses otros 6 meses llega al final del
año y aquí me van a generar el otro
punto por ciento pero no va a ser con
respecto a la cantidad inicial sino a la
que fue generada a los 6 meses así que
lo voy a tener el 4 por ciento o sea la
otra mitad del 8% anual pero de 10.410
mil 400 por 0.04 es igual a 4 por 4 16
llevamos uno bueno aquí dejamos el 1
porque es 4 por 0 0 4 por 14 2 lugares
después del punto decimal nos recorremos
queda aquí mi punto y queda en 416 aquí
se picó el 84 por ciento que faltaba
el 8% anual y estos 416 aquí bueno voy a
poner aquí fueron 400 de interés aquí en
este punto fueron 416 de interés y se
agregan a la cantidad que ya tenía
entonces son 10 mil 400 más 416 vamos a
que tener 10 mil 816 como resultado de
este certificado en su madurez y lo que
nos preguntan es cuál es el interés
total hacia el interés total va a ser la
suma de este interés más este interés
400 más 416 las respuestas 800 16
dólares de interés que es nuestra opción
se me sorprende que esas personas
esperan que ustedes sepan que es el
interés compuesto y espero que la
explicación de que cuando es compuesto
semi anual la cantidad de interés anual
se va a dividir entre dos y se va a
aplicar cada seis meses puede no le
resulte demasiado confusa
en el siguiente vídeo